The fifth major category of issues is heterogeneity.
We started with the assumption, we have a heterogeneous distributed system,
but the dimensions of heterogeneity are many. Hardware, this
not just what kind of computers, but also are there embedded devices involved.
Are there cellphones involved in this? Are there card readers involved?
Are there other, other devices? Different operating systems.
Different programming languages. All of the different standards protocols and
API's that might be involved in building this application. The pieces of
the application that provide access such as a web browsers or these devices.
All of these can change. More over even if they don't change.
Even if they're uniformly applied. That is every part of the system uses
Linux or every part of the system uses Ruby. Are they using the same version?
For example, imagine the issue of testing a web
based application across browser versions. You have three or
four main families of browsers, each coming in three or four different versions.
Also the problem of testing becomes that much more challenging.